[Music]
[Applause]
abstain from meat and save the world
forget Batman today's superheroes are
vegetarians they're really doing
something to help the environment right
weather classic vegetarian vegan or
fruitarian more and more people all over
the world are giving up meat
vegetarianism has even become a status
symbol in many countries but are they
really making a difference let's look at
the data livestock farming has a
terrible carbon footprint look at the 1
billion cattle worldwide raising them
produces vast clouds of greenhouse gases
twice as much as is emitted by planes
globally
and the industry also uses an immense
amount of water around 3000 liters of
h2o go into the production of a single
beefsteak enough to take a shower every
day for three months
and raising animals for me takes up a
lot of space if we all stop eating it
tomorrow it would free up an estimated
30 million square kilometers that's an
area roughly the size of Africa in all
those ways meat really is terrible for
the environment but it's also relative
for example buying an avocado that's
been shipped halfway around the world is
worse for the environment than buying
your steak from a local farmer not least
due to the transport involved so it
really makes the most sense to ask where
is my food coming from local free-range
animals fed largely on grass health
enrich the soil with their manure and
that's good for the environment
some activists even claimed that
free-range cattle could actually help
slow global warming water consumption in
every area of agriculture depends
largely on the farming methods being
employed in the arid regions of Chile
for example where many avocados are
produced it takes around 320 liters of
water to produce a single fruit that's
not exactly low impact agriculture in
other words to make a difference you
should eat things that are in season and
that come from your region so consume
less meat and when you do eat it check
its origins maybe it's time to come up
with another category of environmental
hero the less meat a Tyrian